>> Greg: THIS NEXT STORY
CONTAINS EVERYTHING I HATE ABOUT
MODERN LIFE, CALLOUT CULTURE,
COMPANY COWARDICE, AND PEOPLE
EATING ON SUBWAYS.
SO RIGHT HEARD NATOSHA TIMES,
EYE COLOR FINK CRETE SO THAT
TWEETED A PHOTO OF A D.C.
EMPLOYEE EATING ON A TRAIN AND
REPORTED HER TO HER METRO BOSS
IS SAYING "I THOUGHT WE WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO EAT ON THE TRAIN.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE."
WHAT A NARC.
A TRANSIT OFFICIALS THANKED HER,
BUT SOCIAL MEDIA BACKLASH
ENSUED.
AND I GET IT.
EVEN THOUGH EATING ON A TRAIN'S
BAN, NOBODY LIKES A TATTLETALE.
BUT THEN THE WRITERS PUBLISHED
THE BOOK COMPANY HALTED PRINTING
OF THE LADIES BOOK CITING HER
THINKING ON A BLACK WORKER.
IT DID YOU SEE THE VARIABLE?
IF THINGS WERE NOT ALREADY A
BARREL OF NONCITIZENS, THE MEDIA
HAD TO ADD BRIEFS TO THIS MIX.
SO THE COLD-BLOODED BOOKS WHO
STOP THE PRINTING SAY THAT THEY
HOPE NATASHA LEARNS THAT BLACK
WOMEN FEEL THE SYSTEMATIC RACISM
THE MOST.
SO EVERYTHING THAT MAKES THE
PRESENT DAY A DRAG.
ANNOYING BUSYBODIES WHO USE
TWITTER TO EXERCISE POWER,
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES BREAKING
RULES THAT WE HAVE TO FOLLOW,
AND KNEE-JERK INSTANTANEOUS
CALLS OF RACISM.
THE ONLY THING THAT COULD MAKE
THE STORY MORE ANNOYING AND
DEPRESSING AND STUPID AS IF
SOMEHOW THE PRODUCERS HERE WORK
MAROON 5 INTO IT.
♪ ♪
WELL DONE.
ALL RIGHT, DANA, I DON'T THINK
THAT THE STORY NEEDED A RACIAL
COMPONENT, BUT WHY NOT THROW ONE
IN?
>> Dana: I WAS TRYING TO
THINK, I AM ON THE SUBWAY A LOT.
>> Greg: YOU DO.
>> Dana: I'M NOT THE BOSS OF
THOSE PEOPLE.
IT IS NOT MY PLACE TO SAY YOU
ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BRING YOUR
BIKE ON THE SUBWAY.
BECAUSE MAY BE A GUY REALLY HAS
TO GET TO HIS NEXT JOB, OR WHAT
IF YOU HAVE THE DOG ON THE
SUBWAY.
>> Greg: WHAT IF YOU EAT ON
THE SUBWAY BECAUSE YOU ARE
WORKING THROUGH SHIFTS.
>> Dana: I HAVE EATEN A BAGEL
ON THE SUBWAY.
>> Greg: SHE MIGHT HAVE TWO
JOBS, HER KID MIGHT BE SICK.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON
IN HER LIFE.
I ARGUED THAT THE WRITER WAS NOT
RACIST, BECAUSE SHE DID NOT
NOTICE THE WORKERS RACE, OR SHE
WOULD NOT HAVE DONE IT, BECAUSE
SHE WOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT SHE
WOULD'VE GOTTEN IN TROUBLE.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN SEE WHAT AND
FEEDS ANOTHER HAND IN IDENTITY
POLITICS POKER.
YOU HAVE A BLACK FEMALE
REPUBLICAN UNION EMPLOYEE, HER
HAND BEATS A FEMALE MUSLIM
REPUBLICAN AUTHOR.
>> Greg: SHE IS MUSLIM?
>> Jesse: YES, I RESEARCHED
IT.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
IT IS SNITCHES GET STITCHES.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
AND I HAVE RULES FOR STITCHING,
ONLY THREE TIMES IT IS
ACCEPTABLE.
ONE, SNITCHING ON A STIPPLING
LAMENT SIBLING.
OR TWO ON THE DEEP STATE, THAT
IS WHISTLE-BLOWING.
AND THREE, IF YOU ARE PAID TO
SNITCH LIKE YOU ARE WATCHING A
TRUCK IN MANHATTAN.
BUT HERE IS THE REAL STORY, SHE
WAS NOT SHUCKING CORN.
SHE HAD A CONTAINED PACKAGE.
IT WAS NEAT AND TIDY, THERE IS
NO REASON TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
THE BIGGER STORY IS THAT A
PUBLISHING COMPANY.
THEY SHOULD HAVE CAPITALIZED ON
THIS THING.
THIS WOMAN HAS CREATED AN
AMAZING CONTROVERSY WITH RACE
AND CLASS AND SOCIAL MEDIA AND
THEY FIRED HER INSTEAD OF I
DON'T KNOW, GIVING HER A THREE
BOOK DEAL.
THEY CAN HAVE HER ON NPR, "THE
VIEW."
THEY ARE SO BACKWARDS.
>> Dana: JUST TO TAKE IDENTITY
POLITICS A STEP FURTHER, YOU
KNOW WHO WOULD HAVE GOTTEN A
THREE BOOK DEAL IF THEY DID
THAT?
AN OLDER WHITE MALE.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT WAS
RIGHT.
>> Greg: OF COURSE YOU WOULD,
ONE, BECAUSE YOU HATE WHITE
MALES.
>> Juan: I DON'T LIKE PEOPLE
EATING ON THE SUBWAY, I THINK IT
IS WRONG PAID WHEN I SAW DANA
EATING THAT BAGEL.
I SENT A PICTURE TO OUR BOSSES.
AND I SAID, DO I GET TO --
>> Lisa: YOU GOT THE CORNER
OFFICE ALL OUT OF IT.
>> Juan: WE KNOW FROM
"THE FIVE" COME OF THIS PROGRAM
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
TWITTER IS A VERY SMALL GROUP.
IT IS NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF MOST
OF AMERICA.
THAT IS NOT THE REACTION THAT
MOST PEOPLE ARE HAVING.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE BORED
AND LOOK FOR SOMETHING TO GET
UPSET ABOUT.
I THINK THE WOMAN WAS OUT OF
CONTROL IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
GET THE WOMAN FIRED.
OKAY.
DO I LIKE EATING ON SUBWAYS?
NO, DO I LIKE EMPLOYEES BREAKING
RULES ON THE JOB?
NO.
BUT THE REALITY IS TWITTER OUT
OF CONTROL, AND IF WE JUST DEAL
WITH THIS NOW AS PART OF OUR
LIVES, UNFORTUNATELY EVERYBODY
IS TWEETING ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> Greg: IF THIS IS ANOTHER
CASE WHERE TWITTER COST SOMEBODY
A JOB, AND IT IS FREE.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING PAID TO DO
TWITTER, BUT YOU CAN LOSE YOUR
MONEY.
>> Lisa: IT IS NOT JUST
TWITTER OUT OF CONTROL, BUT IT
IS THE COMPANY IS HELD HOSTAGE
BY TWITTER AND PEOPLE ON
TWITTER, RIGHT?
THE IDEA THAT RACISM HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THIS IS
UTTERLY INSANE.
THE WRITER, AS JESSE POINTS OUT
CALLS HERSELF A MINORITY WRITER.
AND THE WORDS OF RACISM SO
CAVALIERLY, YOU DO THE ALL
GOO -- DEVALUED THE TERM.
IF EVERYBODY IS A RACIST, THAT
USES THE POTENCY.
ALL OF THIS IS DUMB.
I USED TO LIVE IN D.C. AND RODE
THE D.C. METRO, AND YOU DO NOT
WANT PEOPLE EATING ON IT BECAUSE
YOU GET RATS AND IT IS GROSS
LIKE THE NEW YORK SUBWAY.
>> Juan: WE ARE SHORT ON
EMPATHY, SHE HAD NO EMPATHY FOR
THAT WOMAN.
>> Dana: SHE DID NOT GIVE IT
MUCH THOUGHT, YOU TAKE A PICTURE
COMING OUR TWEETING.
>> Greg: I HATE THE WRITERS.
SOMEBODY, NOBODY WANTS TO EAT ON
THE SUBWAY UNLESS THEY HAVE TO.
SO OBVIOUSLY SHE HAD TO EAT
BECAUSE SHE HAD TO GET
SOMEWHERE.
AND THIS LADY APPROACHED HER AND
SAID, YOU CANNOT DO THAT.
SHE SAID MIND HER OWN BUSINESS.